[Musique]
au xviie siècle la france était la plus
grande nation d'europe et la personne de
son roi louis xiv en reflétait toute la
splendeur
il était né pour tenir ce rôle pourrait
être celui qui allait régner 72 ans sur
la france plus longtemps que tout autre
roi de l'histoire tout jeune et fut
associé au brillant dieu du soleil
apollon et c'est ainsi que plus tard on
l'appela communément le roi soleil
fallait qu'il soit tout le temps en
situation d'éblouir ses contemporains le
comportement de louis xiv révèle une
personnalité toute entière'' imprégné de
la notion de règle absolue
il montre vis-à-vis de son entourage
qu'il s'agisse de sa famille de ses
femmes de ses proches conseillers de ces
sujets de la cour des états voisins un
besoin impérieux de domination et de
contrôle il s'appropriait à l'image du
roi soleil et écrivit dans ses mémoires
le soleil par la lumière qu'il
communique aux autres astres qui lui
compose comme une sorte de cour est
assurément la plus vive est la plus
belle image d'un grand monarque
tout au long de son règne il jouit d'un
pouvoir et de privilèges sans précédent
il agrandit son territoire et couronne à
ses succès en construisant l'unité de
son pays
et c'est grâce à lui que la culture
française ébloui le monde entier le roi
soleil était un homme remarquable d'une
envergure exceptionnelle mais qui comme
tout être humain n'était pas parfait il
a parfois confondu sa gloire et celle de
la france
[Musique]
le petit dauphin louis futur louis xiv
n'acquittent au château de saint germain
le 5 septembre 16 138
il était le fils de louis xiii et de son
épouse
l'infante d'espagne de portugal et
archiduchesse d'autriche anne d'autriche
en 1615 nous sommes cinq ans après
l'assassinât de henri iv par ravaillac
mais louis xiii au moment de la mort de
son père à seulement neuf ans donc en le
proclame roi
et puis c'est donc le conseil de régence
qui va gouverner à sa place et ce
conseil de régence se réduit à sa mère
marie de médicis
marie de médicis s'est vu donner une
mission par le bape qui était en somme
ma chère princesse épousé le roi de
france fait lui beaucoup d'enfants bon
catholique
tout son programme politique c'est de
pouvoir amarrer la france au
catholicisme et elle va surpris
voilà alors c'est ça la toile de fond de
ce qui se passe en 1615 c'est à dire la
réalisation de ce qu'est le grand rêve
de marie de médicis le double mariage
espagnol louis xiii épousé anne
d'autriche fille de philippe d'espagne
et arrière petite fille de l'empereur
charles quint et sa soeur élisabeth
épousé le frère dan qui deviendrait
philippe iv en 16 121 en accédant au
trône d'espagne
le fils de louis xiii devait donc hérité
d'une puissance acquise au cours de la
longue lutte pour contrôler l'europe qui
avait opposé les bourbeau aux habsbourg
austro-espagnol les alliances dynastique
forget tout au long du xviie siècle dans
le but de maintenir la paix comme ce
double mariage entre famille royale ne
servir à rien la victoire commençait à
se dessiner en faveur de la france
l'année où louis naquit les deux pays
étaient à court d'argent et désiré la
paire mais chacun voulait que celle-ci
lui soit des plus favorables personne ne
soupçonnait qu'après la naissance d'un
descendant bourbon habsburg la france et
l'espagne resterait en conflit pendant
20 ans louis xiii espérait donner à la
france morcelée sur le plan politique
une identité culturelle qui forgerait
son unité avec son premier ministre
armand jean du plessis cardinal duc de
richelieu
il mena une politique impitoyable qui
restreignait les droits de la noblesse
et accroissent et le pouvoir central de
la monarchie puis 13 ans d'os la
politique préconisée par richelieu et
petit à petit on s'écarte
progressivement de l'espagne et dans les
années 1600 29 1630 on ne se fait pas
ouvertement la guerre mais on est dans
des camps opposés
vers la fin de sa vie richelieu désigne
à son successeur en le cardinal italien
jules mazarin un ancien émissaire du
pape et lui confia la mission de
poursuivre son ambition créer une france
forte indépendante et alliés de
l'espagne
louis xiv c'est en quelque sorte
l'enfant du miracle c'est louis
dieudonné sa naissance fait suite à une
longue période d'incertitude et de très
mauvaises relations au sein du couple
royal
la naissance de louis fut célébré en
grande pompe il assurait la succession
au trône
ce don richelieu et mazarin à des
besoins pour marquer le début de leur
projet richelieu mourut en 16140 de
quelques mois seulement avant louis xiii
on dit que louis xiv fut toujours
conscient de sa condition et du rôle
qu'il jouerait plus tard quand il fut
appelé au chevet de son père mourant le
roi demande à qui s est le jeune dauphin
qui avait à peine cinq ans répondit
louis xiv
il n'avait que trois semaines d'avancé
sur son avènement
la naissance même de louis semblait un
signe divin il était le premier né de
ses parents qu'il attendait depuis 23
ans
son arrivée fait considéré comme un
miracle un cadeau de dieu au peuple de
france à la mort de louis xiii le 14 mai
16 143 anne d'autriche de vin régente
elle partagea immédiatement son pouvoir
avec l'ancien premier ministre protégés
de richelieu le cardinal jules mazarin
une régence pour les nobles c'est
toujours une période où ils se disent
qu'il va y avoir des opportunités et des
opportunités fortes puisque louis xiii
et surtout richelieu les avait exclues
du pouvoir
donc ils pensaient que ce serait un
retour en force
or voilà que surprise la reine anne
d'autriche dont il pensait qu'elles leur
était très favorable va continuer avec
mazarin à appliquer la politique de son
défunt mari et du détestait cardinal de
richelieu louis xiv accéder au trône
mais ne prenez pas en personne les rênes
du gouvernement il lui fallu pour cela
attendre 18 ans et la mort de son
premier ministre
mazarin dont on pense qu'il fut l'amant
d'anne d'autriche s'employa à faire du
jeune garçon leroy qui servirait son
projet pour la france
dès son plus jeune âge il l'emmena des
réunions du conseil
ils étaient présents lorsqu'il recevait
des diplomates étrangers
il encourageait louis lorsque celui ci
jouait la guerre avec ses amis et
l'emmener admirer les troupes pour
éveiller son intérêt pour les affaires
militaires à l'âge de 7 ans l'enfant roi
était en mesure de porter une arme et il
devint vite un excellent cavalier tout
comme sa mère
louis était le grand amour d'anne
d'autriche sa naissance avait renforcé
sa position au sein du royaume
elle passait plus de temps avec son
enfant que la plupart des femmes de la
cour
en revanche la reine portait bien peu
d'attention à son second fils philippe
duc d'orléans et le traité souvent comme
une fille
le trône c'est considéré comme une co
propriété familiale
on était dans un système on peut dire
complètement féodal par sa conception
dans lequel une famille une famille
élargie avec les cousins et neveux les
collatéraux et c'est une famille est
propriétaire donc d'un bien d'une
principauté ou d'un royaux et donc quand
marie de médicis décide de se faire
proclamer seulement les jantes ça
provoque wahba ça provoque évidemment
les grincements de dents de tous les
princes de la famille royale qui
considèrent bas et qu'ils ont de façon
naturelle une part au gâteau louis
avaient tout juste 10 ans en 16 148
quand le pays connut une période de
guerre civile appelée la fronde qui
allait bouleverser la france pendant
quatre ans c'est une révolte dans les
historiens ont beaucoup peiné à trouver
le sens je dirais que c'est la dernière
le dernier soubresaut de tout le royaume
de france puisqu'il est à une fronde des
nobles une fronde des parlementaires
une dernière réaction face à
l'affirmation de l'absolutisme la fronde
était une réaction au pouvoir croissant
de mazarin et d'anne d'autriche tous
deux étrangers et qui menaçait en
permanence de déplacer le pouvoir du
parlement vers la couronne
c'est donc un épisode dramatique au
cours duquel
anne d'autriche et mazarin on était à
deux doigts de perdre le pouvoir et le
jeune louis xiv l'a vécu très
intensément et ça va marquer de sa vie
durant sa relation avec son entourage et
surtout à la chose politique
à d'autriche va admirablement manoeuvrer
et c'est son comportement son habileté
elle est bien conseillé par mazars mais
c'est son habilité malgré un caractère
qui a un caractère très fort
elle ne supporte pas les eaux france qui
sont faites au pouvoir royal temps en
temps c'est mazarin plus onctueux qui
lui dit il faut faire semblant de céder
et puis on n'en sera que plus fort après
pour gagner la bataille suivante
et tout ceci fait qu'elles préservent le
trône est que lorsque louis xiv va être
en mesure d'exercer le pouvoir personnel
il a vraiment en main absolument toutes
les cartes et des cartes extrêmement
forte
et ça il le doit à sa mère malgré des
épisodes terrifiant pour la famille
royale
cette tentative de contrer la
centralisation du pouvoir fut un échec
mais loué n'oubliera pas et punira plus
tard les nobles et les membres de la
famille royale dont il sentait qu'il
l'avait trahi
au cours de cette révolte louis xiv a
été l'élève de mazarin qui lui inculquer
l'idée qu'il devait être le plus grand
roi d'europe
c'est dire la vision qu'il en a elle est
très élevé il a très intimement
conscience surcroît d'être le
représentant vivant de dieu sur terre
et ça ça impose une majesté accrue et il
a la volonté
on pourrait même dire la volonté
forcenée de s'affirmer comme le plus
glorieux roi d'europe
au début des années 16 150 mazarin et
andy son tutorat en instruisant
quotidiennement le jeune roi des
affaires intérieures et extérieures de
la france dans les dernières années de
sa vie
louis avait alors entre 15 et 22 ans ils
impliquent a dans toutes les affaires de
l'état
le jeune homme commence à a présidé les
réunions du conseil et à accueillir les
dignitaires étrangers en visite
officielle
pendant la majeure partie de la vie de
louis xiii la france et l'espagne fut
rengaine le jeune roi puis donc instruit
dans l'art de gouverner un pays qui se
devait d'être victorieux mais manquaient
cruellement d'argent à sa majorité louis
avait hérité de sa mère et de son père
de substitution un grand sens de sa
responsabilité envers dieu puisqu'il
était roi de droit divin
sa mission était d'user de cette
autorité pour devenir l'incarnation de
la gloire de la france
à 14 ans lou et participe à un ballet et
dans sa le rôle d'apollon le dieu du
soleil
il dégageait une majesté naturelle et
cultivés avec soin son image de roi
soleil
[Musique]
2635 en 1659 c'est la guerre la guerre
ouverte avec des hauts et des bas des
répits mais c'est toujours la guerre
avec l'espagne et ça va donc se terminer
en 16 159 le traité des pyrénées mis fin
à la guerre d'espagne
il prévoyait le mariage du jeune roi de
france à l'infante marie-thérèse
d'autriche fille du roi d'espagne
il fut signée en territoire neutre sur
l'île des faisans au milieu de la
rivière bidassoa qui séparait les deux
pays et ont dit le meilleur gage de la
réconciliation c'est évidemment un
mariage espagnol
alors on sait par l'expérience de louis
xiii et anne d'autriche que ça ne règle
pas tout mais on se dit n'empêche il
vaut mieux être allié par la famille par
les liens du sang que ne pas avoir de
liens du tout et c'est pour ça que ce
mariage à une très très grosse
importance politique parce que c'est on
clôt la période de l'affrontement entre
la france et l'espagne
louis et son épouse furent accueillis à
paris par la foule en liesse
anne d'autriche et mazarin avaient
accompli leur tâche
le cardinal mouret l'année suivante en
16 161 louis avait alors 22 ans
le pape n'a pas de pouvoir sur lui l
empereur n'a pas de pouvoir sur lui
alors évidemment ça énerve les papes au
plus haut point ça énerve les habsbourgs
mais le roi de france dit moi je ne vous
dois rien je ne dois de compte que à
dieu et à ma conscience
après la mort de mazarin louis xiv
s'empara des rênes du pouvoir et
travaille à le consolider
sa première tâche fut de punir la
noblesse indocile il bannit du conseil
royal tous les membres de la noblesse et
ne se choisit pas de premier ministre ni
lors de son avènement
ni plus tard ce coup d'état stupéfié la
cour à sa mort mazarin était un homme
riche
il laissa louis toute sa fortune c'est
collection de sculptures d'oeuvres d'art
et de mobilier mais on dit que son
cadeau le plus précieux fut jean
baptiste colbert qui fut le principal
conseiller de louis durant vingt ans il
lui permis d'accomplir le projet de
riches au lieu de consolider le pouvoir
de la france colbert ça va être le
nouvel homme fort mais ça ne sera pas un
principe à la ministre c'est un ministre
d'état mais qui va être l'auxiliaire
dévoué et qui avec sa famille va devenir
un des clans les plus puissants puisque
colbert va s'assurer le contrôle général
des finances
les bâtiments du roi la marine par le
biais de sa famille et toute la
direction aussi de la politique
économique du royaume
colbert remplace avec fracas le
surintendant des finances de louis xiii
nicolas fouquet et colbert était dingue
l'extraction mais mazarin avait décelé
en lui une intelligence supérieure dès
son plus jeune âge sous louis xiv il
devait devenir le plus remarquable
administrateur de l'histoire de france
le roi avait déjà remis à leur place ses
ennemis et raffermit son pouvoir à
présent seconde et par colbert ils
allaient pouvoir moderniser la france
le véritable début de son règne est
marquée par une série de réformes
administratives et fiscales les caisses
du royaume sont vides
colbert réforme le système financier il
réduit la dette nationale
en instituant des impôts plus efficace
la dîme et les douanes étaient des
formes de taxation coutumière la gabelle
un impôt sur le sel et la taille sur la
terre colbert lance également un grand
programme de travaux publics et
travaille à développer les échanges
commerciaux
[Musique]
puis il remodèle la marine royale
l'avait guère d'envergure par ses forces
militaires
louis xiv supplante à cette époque les
pays-bas dans son rôle de pivot de
l'europe vers l'est
[Musique]
bien que son véritable domaine fut le
commerce
colbert occupe à tous les secteurs du
gouvernement à l'exception de celui de
la guerre et son travail porta ses
fruits
en dix ans de 16 cents 61,16 171 après
la mort de mazarin et la fin de la
guerre d'espagne
il parvient à rétablir l'équilibré
économique du pays et à doubler le
revenu national
à sa mort en 16 183 celui ci était
quatre fois celui de l'angleterre et
près de dix fois celui de la république
de venise
tout cela va se heurter à la politique
belliqueuse de louis xiv qui elle va
être coûteuse et va contrecarrer cet
effort de redressement économique
jusqu'à nos jours le roi soleil est
connu pour avoir été un protecteur des
arts est un mécène généreux sa
motivation elle est simple c'est être le
plus puissants souverains d'europe et le
manifestaient dans la pierre dans les
divertissements dans les bals dans les
faits d' bref éblouir en 16 167 louis
fond de l'académie des sciences et
l'observatoire royal jusqu'à sa mort il
continuera à créer des académies et des
fondations scientifique pour qu'elle
mène des activités qu'elle préside en
chantant les louanges de la figure
transcendante du roi soleil c'est le
mécénat du roi soleil qui permis
l'épanouissement de la littérature
française à travers des écrivains comme
molière racine et la fontaine dont les
oeuvres ont toujours autant de
retentissement de nos jours
les arts visuels également trouvèrent un
protecteur en louis xiv il subventionne
à et passe à des commandes à des
artistes comme charles le brun pierre
mignard antoine quoi ce box et hyacinthe
rigaud dont les oeuvres étaient admirés
dans toute l'europe en musique des
compositeurs et musiciens comme jean
baptiste lully jacques champion de
chambonnière et françois couperin pur
s'épanouir et influencer les générations
suivantes au cours des années 16 160 le
travail acharné de colbert et
l'efficacité de son administration
permira louis de lui laisser la tâche de
reconstruire la france et de se tourner
vers le projet qui lui tenait à coeur
il voulait se retirer à distance de la
capitale et reconstruire versailles
l'ancien rendez vous de chasse de son
père
colbert fut incapable d'arrêter les
dépenses faramineuses que nécessitait la
construction de versailles et les
campagnes militaires il n'aura aucun
successeur
et lorsqu'il mourra le trésor devra de
nouveau faire face à la faillite
les rois avaient souvent coutume d'avoir
une épouse choisi pour des raisons
politiques et une maîtresse officielle
davantage à son goût mais avec louis les
relations amoureuses se succèdent à un
rythme qui dépassaient la norme
en même temps louis était un jeune homme
pieux ils avaient de grandes
connaissances en théologie ne manquait
jamais d'observer les rites de l'église
et s'efforçait de ne pas pêcher il est
une question que l'on se pose et à
laquelle il est difficile de répondre
comment louis s'arroger t-il avec la
contradiction évidente entre ces
liaisons extramaritales et son lien avec
dieu
louis xiv se confessait de ses frasques
et ses directeurs de conscience
successifs lui disait lui conseiller
toujours de rejoindre un peu plus le
chemin de la vertu mais eh bien il se
laissait aller aussi à ce qui était la
nature humaine admettre les péchés du
roi c'était aussi une façon de ne pas
contrarier le grand dessein royal qui
était de donner au royaume de france
tout son lustre et toute sa force
politique
le roule quasi divin qu'il devait
assumer provoqua chez le jeune roi des
moments de doute et un manque de
confiance en soi
il avait été élevé dans l'idée que
chacun devait l'admirer ceux-ci liées au
besoin d'être rassurés peut expliquer en
partie qu'il n'ait pu résister aux
nombreuses avances des plus belles
femmes de la cour
[Musique]
le jeune louis vécu une passion pour
l'exquise marie mancini il tomba
amoureux d'elle alors qu'il n'avait que
18 ans mais sa mère et mazars à lui
interdire ce qu'il considérait comme une
mésalliance le cardinal fit tout pour
l'en décourager
et arrange a pour lui un mariage
diplomatique avec la nièce d'anne
d'autriche
la jeune infante marie thérèse d'espagne
le coeur brisé
louis accepta par devoir d'épousé
l'infante à saint jean de luz le 9 juin
16 160 il n'était pas amoureux d'elle
mais il fut touché et flatté par l'amour
qu'elle lui portait malgré ses
infidélités louis ne cessa jamais de
traiter la reine son épouse avec
courtoisie et une tendresse affiché il
ne voulait pas qu'on puisse penser qu'il
ne l'aimait pas et avec le temps il
s'est pris profondément d'elle le grand
dauphin louis de france seul enfant
survivant de louis xiv et de marie
thérèse naquit l'année suivante en 16
il est difficile de savoir combien de
fois la reine fut enceinte mais on sait
qu'elle fit au moins six fausses couches
en 761 le frère du roi philippe duc
d'orléans qu'on appelait monsieur épouse
à henriette anne d'angleterre qui ne
tarda pas devenir la maîtresse de louis
anne d'autriche été choqué par le
comportement de son fils pour éviter sa
colère henrietta suggéra louis de
feindre de s'intéresser à une de ses
suivantes ce qui permettrait de garder
leur relation secrète mauvaise idée car
il ne fait guère de temps pour que la
jeune femme censée servir de couverture
à leurs amours tombe elle aussi dans les
bras du roi henriette avait choisi la
jeune et virginale louise de la vallière
celle-ci impressionné par le caractère
divin de son souverain tomba amoureuse
de l'homme lui-même il fut séduit par
ses cheveux blonds ses yeux bleus sa
peau pâle sa timidité et l'adoration
qu'elle lui portait et il l'a pris pour
maîtresse
malgré ses multiples infidélités louis
retourna toujours dormir auprès de sa
femme leur relation ne s'interrompit que
quelques mois lorsque la reine se retira
pour protester contre sa liaison avec
louise de la vallière anne d'autriche dû
intervenir pour que les choses rentrent
dans l'ordre
louis promis alors à son épouse que
lorsqu'il aurait atteint ses 30 ans ils
changeraient ses manières et se
montrerait un bon mari
louis xiv sa vie durant va être l'enfant
fidèle d'un d'autriche on connaît sa
douleur à la mort de la reine et on peut
même dire que cette espèce d'amour de
relations qui lient à entre la mère et
le fils va peut-être d'une certaine
manière miner sa relation avec marie
thérèse son épouse dans laquelle il
verra toujours quelqu'un de moins
brillants de moins politique que sa mère
dont aimé la reine marie thérèse et sa
belle-mère étaient devenus très proches
quand anne d'autriche meurt le 20
janvier 766 louis père une mère qui
avait toujours veillé sur lui et la
reine sa plus grande alliée à la cour
on sait que tous deux pleurèrent
beaucoup louise de la vallière eu quatre
enfants avec le roi dont deux seulement
survécurent marianne princesse de conte
y était sans doute la plus jolie des
filles de louis xiv il l'a gâtée
terriblement mais au moment de sa
naissance à l'automne 767 louise fut
peiné en apprenant une nouvelle
infidélité du roi athenais de
rochechouart de mortemart marquise de
montespan suivante intelligente et
ambitieuse s'était servie de l'amitié
que lui porte et louise de la vallière
pour gagner l'affection du roi
louise étant enceinte de son quatrième
enfant il ne fut pas difficile de le
distraire et athénaïs de montespan
devint sa nouvelle maîtresse
[Musique]
madame de sévigné a décrit sa beauté
louis l'a trouvée fascinante
il n'était pas vraiment faits l'un pour
l'autre mais le roi pensaient qu'il se
devait de conquérir les plus belles
femmes de france louise était discrète
et sa jeunesse s'enfuyait elle ne tient
pas la comparaison avec l'intrépide est
splendide descendante des mortemart
louis cela ça d'elle
[Musique]
en 774 mademoiselle de la vallière
compris qu'elle avait perdue elle se
jeta publiquement au pied de la reine et
implorer son pardon
puis elle pris le voile et entra au
couvent chez les carmélites
on espérait qu athénaïs ferait de même
mais il n'en fut rien elle invite à
françoise d'aubigné scaron future madame
de maintenon une ancienne connaissance
d'eux-mêmes extraction pour être
gouvernante des bâtards hoyaux
le roi l'a récompensé pour son
dévouement et lui donna une grosse somme
d'argent
elle acheta ainsi la propriété et le
château de maintenon située à 50
kilomètres de versailles et pris le
titre de madame de maintenon
madame de maintenon c'est la personne
qui a eu le plus d'influencé sur le roi
et une influence certaine dans des actes
politiques majeurs qui ont engagé la vie
du royaume sur des dizaines d'années
voire plus comme la révocation de l'édit
de nantes
le manque d'intérêt de madame de
montespan pour ses enfants jouent en sa
défaveur car le roi et met ses rejetons
et leur porter un grand intérêt il
appréciait la tendresse maternelle et le
comportement naturel de madame de
maintenon avec les enfants françoise à
présent madame de maintenon était une
jeune femme séduisante dont la chevelure
et les yeux noirs faisait l'admiration
de tous son intérêt sincère pour le
salut du roi les conversations franches
qu'il pouvait avoir avec elle le
conduisirent petit à petit à la
considérer comme une amie et une
confidente
il est fort possible que madame de
montespan est perçue l'élévation de sa
gouvernante dans l'échelle sociale comme
un danger
[Musique]
oh
e
en 775 après des années d'attac voilée
sur le comportement adultérin du roi
l'église catholique agi de façon directe
un prêtre tendu un guet-apens à la
maîtresse du roi
il lui refusa le sacrement de pénitence
pendant la semaine sainte l'empêchant
ainsi de communier à pâques
louis athénaïs d'urss engagées à
éteindre les flammes de leur passion en
fait le roi commençait à s'inquiéter du
jugement de dieu
à propos de ces liaisons extramaritales
l'évêque bossuet et d'autres grands
prédicateurs de l'époque l'admonestation
de leur cher depuis des années les
larmes et les prières que sa mère avait
versé pour son salut dix ans plus tôt le
hantait bossuet et madame de maintenon
travailler ensemble pour amener le
couple à mettre un terme à leur liaison
pour des raisons religieuses
de retour de flandre de la guerre de
hollande le roy assure à bossuet qu'ils
n'avaient plus à s'inquiéter puisque
madame de montespan vivait désormais à
clanique oui ici répondit bossuet mais
dieu serait je crois plus content sic
l'ani était à 60 lieux de paris l'évêque
avait raison ayant fréquenté quelques
temps cette femme irrésistible
il prévoyait qu'il serait difficile aux
rois de s'en défaire louez permis bien
vite athénaïs de revenir à la cour en
stipulant qu'elle ne pourrait le voir
qu'en présence de ses chaperons mais ces
bonnes résolutions furent bien vite mise
à mal et leur tombèrent dans les bras
l'un de l'autre
les grâces de madame de montespan retard
l'insatiable souverain pendant plus de
dix ans mais après qu'elle eut mise au
monde plusieurs enfants sont poidevin le
centre des conversations à la cour et la
passion de louis pour son épouse secrète
arriva à son terme
il avait alors 40 ans
à l'hiver 16 178 qui suivit la guerre de
hollande
l'histoire semble à se répéter bien que
peu doué intellectuellement on la disait
saute comme un panier
angélique de fontanges âgé de 18 ans
était la plus grande beauté que jamais
vu la cour elle n'eut aucune difficulté
à réaliser son ambition de séduire le
roi il couche avec elle dit on la
première fois qu'il la vie et tenta de
garder cette liaison secrète surtout aux
yeux de madame de montespan et de madame
de maintenon
mais il devint bientôt évident pour tous
que le roi était devenu l'esclave de
cette jeune beauté
très vite elle lui donna désordre ce
qu'aucune autre n'avait jamais osé elle
devint duchesse est la maîtresse du roi
en un éclair ne voyons pas en elle une
rivale madame de montespan ne fit rien
dans les premiers temps pour arrêter
l'ascension d'angélique de fontanges
mais lorsqu'elle a appris qu'elle avait
été faite duchesse titre qui ne lui
avait jamais été accordée elle entra en
furie mademoiselle de fontanges ne garda
pas longtemps les faveurs de louis et
fut congédié
tout comme mademoiselle de la vallière
[Musique]
loi envoya madame de maintenon lui
annoncer la nouvelle
celle ci dit ensuite j'y suis resté deux
heures et j'ai passé le temps à tenter
de la persuader de ne plus apporte une
et le roi je me souviens qu'elle a
répondu avec une certaine vivacité mais
madame vous me dites de quitter cette
passion comme s'il s'agissait de quitter
une chemise elle finit par mourir dans
un couvent à l'âge de 20 ans après avoir
donné naissance à un enfant mort né
on soupçonne à un empoisonnement il
fallu pratiquer une autopsie qui
n'apporte à rien de concluant à cette
époque la litanie des infidélités du roi
était connue de tous
de son côté il était devenu plus
soucieux de sa réputation
et si lorsqu'il était plus jeune
c'est badinage pouvait être acceptée
comme des marques de fougue et de
générosité
à présent qu'il avançait en âge son
grand appétit était considéré comme un
avis et entamait son autorité auprès de
la cour certes madame de maintenant avec
quelques années de plus que le roi était
de modeste extraction est la veuve d'un
écrivain sulfureux mais elle lui était
néanmoins d'un grand réconfort du
prodiguant conseils et encouragements en
16 280 deux loups étaient censés avoir
renoncé au péché de chair il se dévoie
tout entier à la reine marie thérèse
enchanté de jouir enfin d attention sans
partage du roi mais il semblait bien
pourtant que le corps du roi était
attaché ailleurs quand la cour comme
tous les ans se rendit à fontainebleau
madame de maintenon ya là aussi bien que
madame de montespan reste à versailles
et quand l'euro à la visite et ses
régiments en mai de la même année
madame de maintenon encore une fois
accompagné la reine la joie de celle ci
fut de courte durée
dès son retour à versailles elle
développe à un abcès sous le bras et
mourut deux mois plus tard à la fin de
juillet 16 183 maintenant âgé de 46 ans
au lieu d'envisager une nouvelle union à
visée politique
ce qui risquait de faire éclater de
nouvelle dispute entre demi frère pour
l'accession au trône
louis xiv épouse a secrètement sa
meilleure amie et son grand amour
madame de maintenant personne n'était au
courant
l'union fut scellée à l'église mais
l'état n'y était pas mêlé la question du
salut de son âme étant résolus louis
promise à françoise de lui être fidèle
mais elle ne deviendra jamais reine de
france il n'aura plus d'autre maîtresse
les aventures amoureuses font désormais
partie d'une époque révolue
en choisissant madame de maintenon louis
marque des points sur le plan politique
il gagne une autorité religieuse
nouvelles auprès de la cour et a
maintenant à son côté une campagne
loyale qui lui rappelle très fort le
modèle maternelle
après ce mariage les préceptes religieux
furent observés avec plus de rigueur et
le roi mena une vie privée marquée au
sceau de la vertu comme on le lui
prêchait depuis si longtemps
[Applaudissements]
la lente évolution d'un système féodal
un gouvernement central moderniser
marque à un grand changement pour
beaucoup de français
ils furent libérés de leur devoir
d'obéissance envers leur seigneur et
eurent le droit de se lancer dans le
commerce et par là même de sortir de la
pauvreté
mais l'amélioration de la vie de ces
sujets n'étaient nullement le souci du
roi il cherchait simplement à accroître
son pouvoir
plus encore que son père louis xiv
pensait que le monarque devait être la
seule autorité politique de la france
sur le plan national il réussi à
accroître son influence et à instaurer
une autorité centralisée détenus par la
couronne au détriment de l'aristocratie
ainsi que de l'église la centralisation
c'est beaucoup plus une politique
beaucoup plus que des textes de loi
d'abord pourquoi la centralisation alors
la raison de base c'est que la france
n'est pas du tout un pays unifié c'est
pas un pays unitaire la france jusqu'à
la révolution française c'est un pays
qui est fait de pièces et de morceaux il
y à des territoires dans tous les sens
de petite taille de grande taille
il ya des privilèges dans tous les sens
et dans ce patchwork donc le roi ne fait
pas ce qu'il veut il est obligé de
respecter les accords et qui ont été
ainsi passés mais évidemment il ne se
prive pas d'essayer de les grignoter
colbert s'est d'abord attelé à accroître
le contrôle de l'économie et de la
culture par le pouvoir central
réduire l'autonomie des provinces allait
être le défi suivant pour obtenir la
centralisation du pouvoir il va priver
méthodiquement la noblesse provincial
française de ses droits de
représentation
la décision de louis de quitter paris le
louvre pour faire de versailles du
palais royal provoqua les premiers
mouvements de mécontentement au sein de
la noblesse la perturber la vie de ces
privilégiés qui jouait ses désavantages
de la vie citadine
seuls les hommes de grande endurance ou
des gardes et des activités à paris et à
versailles simultanément mais louis ne
s'arrêta pas là il se lança dans un mode
de vie qui allaient éloigner encore plus
de la cour les gentilshommes provinciaux
la noblesse du 16e siècle était très
différente de celle du règne de louis
xiv il n'était pas dans les habitudes
d'un seigneur de province de fréquenter
la cour il restait dans ses terres et de
traiter ces affaires sur place
l'organisation de la cour par louis xiv
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre de politique
parce que il y avait évidemment des
reste très fort de féodalité que le
henri iv avait déjà amoindri
les nouveaux usages obligèrent nombre de
ces seigneurs adopté le style de vie des
courtisans le chef-d'oeuvre politique de
qe versailles c'est de faire en sorte
que les seigneurs n'ai plus envie d'être
dans leur château est d'être parmi
l'argent et qui n'est rien de plus
pressé de plus important pour eux que
d'être vu par le roi ou d'avoir une
petite fonction parfois des fonctions de
domesticité de grands seigneurs ont
accepté d'être gentilhomme de la cour
pour avoir l'honneur de tenir le
vêtement du roi pour avoir l'honneur de
lui porter son épée d'assister au
coucher au lever royal à toutes ces
scènes de la vie publique où il fallait
être vu louis poursuivi donc l'oeuvre de
ses prédécesseurs en créant un état
centralisé gouverné depuis la capitale
éliminant ainsi les vestiges du
féodalisme qui persistait dans certaines
parties de la france en supprimant la
hiérarchie traditionnelle du système
féodal
il voyait son pouvoir se développer
pendant ce temps là pendant que les
seniors sont à la cour eh bien on envoie
des intendants et celles à louis xiv
sebha seulement le triomphe de la course
et le trion des intendants c'est ce
qu'on appellera plus tard des préfets
mais c'est un temps dans ce sont eux qui
vont diriger les duchés les périls et
seigneuries et ils vont remplacer les
seigneurs mais c'est un temps dans ils
seront complètement aux ordres du
pouvoir royal et de grands hauts
fonctionnaires tels que colbert
louer se méfiait des allégeances il
considérait aussi le pape comme un
danger à l'égard de sa souveraineté il
chercha à renforcer le gallicanisme
doctrine qui limite l autorité du pape
il convoquera une assemblée des claviers
astique l'assemblée du clergé en 16 180
qui approuvent à la déclaration du
clergé de france le roi était autorisé à
promulguer des lois ecclésiastiques et
toutes les règles édictées par le pape
était soumise à l'assentiment du
monarque
cette déclaration ne fut pas acceptée
par le pape
ce qui n'était pas étonnant dans la
mesure où elle battait en brèche son
autorité louis xiv ainsi que la cour des
ménages a officiellement à versailles le
6 mai 16 182 loi avait plusieurs raisons
de vouloir créer un tel symbole
d'opulence et de grandeur et changer le
siège de la monarchie
ce bouleversement contribuer à asseoir
son pouvoir
il considérait versailles comme un
centre de décision à l'écart des
manifestations de révolte et de trahison
comme la france les avait connus sous la
fronde
[Musique]
dans ce lieu entièrement sous contrôle
les nobles considérait comme un honneur
voir un privilège de dîner à la table du
roi ou de porter le chandelier qui
allaient l'éclairer il n'était plus en
mesure d'exercer aucun pouvoir ou de
créer des troubles
nous avons beaucoup d'informations sur
la cour de louis xiv
grâce au duc de saint-simon ami de
longue date du roi et à la seconde femme
de monsieur frère du roi la princesse
palatine
ils nous rendent compte de façon plus
utile des moeurs de la cour que
l'historien entretenue par le pouvoir
l'auteur dramatique préférée du roi jean
racine
les écrits de la marquise de sévigné
constitue aussi une source intéressante
cet intellectuel belle et charmante et
est souvent invitée aux fêtes royales et
tenait une correspondance très libre où
elle décrivait les événements de la cour
la beauté du roi déclinait mais sa
présence pleine d'autorité ne faisait
que grandir à versailles louis xiv
développe à l'art du spectacle dans
toute sa magnificence
mais il faut aussi y voir la marque
d'une stratégie très étudié le roi ne
cherchait pas seulement impressionné ses
sujets à cette époque les rois avaient
l'habitude dans toute l'europe de vider
les coffres de l'état pour bâtir des
châteaux de plus en plus vastes comme en
toute chose
louis xiv pouce à cette stratégie à
l'extrême la façade avait une importance
capitale
d'un point de vue figuratif et littérale
en fait la splendeur affiché de
versailles était plus importante que le
caractère pratique de sa conception ou
le confort de ses habitants quand on dit
au roi que les feux refoulerait de la
fumée à l'intérieur du bâtiment
s'il en a grandi c'est pas les cheminées
sur les toits il choisi de supporter cet
inconvénient plutôt que d' altérer
l'ordre extérieur et la symétrie de son
château
[Musique]
et
à l'apogée du règne de louis xiv le
château de versailles y comptait dix
mille habitants
son entretien nécessitait 5000 personnes
la structure sociale était basé sur un
système héréditaire qui courent est de
la plus haute à la plus humble des
positions
[Musique]
le grand appartement était un élément
central dans le rituel de la vie à la
cour
telle qu'elle avait été planifié par le
roi on se rassembler chaque matin pour
aller en procession à la messe et trois
fois par semaine pour les
divertissements du soir ap les
appartements au cours de la soirée on se
divertissaient par la comédie les jeux
d'argent le billard et la musique
c'était une façon pour louis xiv de
contrôler les nobles venu vivre à
versailles auprès de lui
fontainebleau était la plus charmante et
des résidences royales et le seul palais
où louis ne fit pas exécuté de
transformation majeure il aimait se
retirer de temps à autre avec sa cour
dans ce château ancien et romantique
particulièrement pendant la saison de
chasse marly la maison de plaisir de
louis xiv avait été conçu pour que le
roi puisse se détendre échappé à l'avis
de la cour et mener la vie d'un simple
gentilhomme campagnard pour quelques
jours à marly en oublia l'étiquette
aussi les invitations était elle très
convoité
et pour ceux qui avaient la chance d'y
être invité louis était un hôte généreux
on note dans le caractère du roi soleil
certaines contradictions intéressante il
était presque trop poli est observée
avec rigueur tout ce que lui impose l
étiquette mais il pouvait aussi être
brutal avec ces gens et se plaisait même
parfois à humilier les autres au premier
abord cela semble contradictoire mais
c'est très concours tous au même
résultat
louis a toujours eu pour but de celle
vers un piédestal de plus en plus haut
afin que chacun puisse l'admirer
on peut donc penser que ses bonnes
manières affichée et ses gestes brutaux
de domination lui permettait dans un cas
comme dans l'autre d'aspirer le respect
pour ce qui est de l'état
louez place a toujours son devoir au
dessus de ses sentiments personnels
en seize 179 quand il apprit que le roi
charles ii d'espagne était en état de se
marier il voulu immédiatement empêcher
qu'un autrichien gagne l'appui de
l'espagne et offrir rapidement en
mariage la fille préférée de son frère
philippe marie louise d'orléans
c'était une jeune femme charmante elle
fut terrifiés à cette nouvelle charles
ii était un homme y de handicapés est
déficient mental sans doute était ce la
conséquence de mariages consanguins
fréquents chez les habsbourg
elle avait espéré que son oncle lui
permettrait d'épouser son premier cousin
le dauphin louis de rester dans sa
patrie est de devenir peut-être un jour
reine de france
bien que le roi eut beaucoup d'affection
pour la fille aînée de son frère une
alliance avec son fils n'était pas le
meilleur usage qu'on pouvait tirer de
son rang de seconde dame du royaume
louis gardel le dauphin pour conclure
une alliance avec l'allemagne avant son
départ la jeune fille laplaud rade ne
pas l'obliger à partir mais louis
demeura imperturbable il attendait
d'elle qu'elle accepte son destin est
rempli son devoir d'envoyer de la france
marie-louise ne remit jamais le pied sur
le sol natal à la cour d'espagne
elle tomba dans une profonde dépression
et mourut dix ans plus tard
à l'âge de 26 ans les décisions
politiques de louis ne témoignait pas
toujours d'un jugement solide mais le
devoir dynastique des membres de la cour
dépendent est clairement de son autorité
et dans ce domaine il était entièrement
dévoués au bien de son état lorsqu'il
déplaçait la cour de versailles à
fontainebleau ou marly ou l'emmenait sur
les champs de bataille il ajoutait aux
tensions existantes en obligeant la
reine a partagé sa voiture avec une deux
ou trois de ses maîtresses il les force
est également à voyager alors qu'elle
était malade ou enceinte malgré les avis
des médecins était ce en raison de sa
propre constitution que louis ne
comprenait pas les difficultés de son
entourage car ils jouissaient d'une
santé robuste il était très rarement
malade il aimait être dehors même durant
les hivers les plus rudes et insistait
pour que les fenêtres de sa voiture soit
toujours ouverte
madame de maintenon devait se blottir
sous des couvertures pour ne pas
attraper mal car il aimait que les
fenêtre de sa chambre soit grande
ouverte
même en hiver l'énergie de louis était
encore intacte au milieu de sa vie
connu pour son comportement glouton il
gardait un appétit d'ogre la princesse
palatine la femme de son frère raconte
comment elle a souvent vu le roi dévorer
à faisant entier et une perdrix
après quatre assiettes de différentes
soupes un grand plat de salades deux
grandes tranches de jambon du mouton à
l'ail avec de la sauce un plateau de
gâteaux sucrés et par dessus le tout un
fruit et des oeufs durs
malheur aux courtisans obligée
d'accompagner le roi est bien que celui
ci souffrait d'une goutte douloureuse
qui le cloud est parfois dans un
fauteuil roulant
il continue à attirer et à chasser
jusqu'à un âge avancé
même s'il lui fallait utiliser une
petite voiture pour cela
louis n'était ni ignorants ni insensible
il était capable d'éprouver une grande
tristesse et de l'empathie mais le rôle
de roi soleil exerçait sur lui une
pression incroyable
[Musique]
louis xiv avait un formidable appétit de
vivre et un éclat comme aucun autre roi
de france n'en avait tué avant lui au
milieu de sa vie et après beaucoup de
luttes intérieures il résolu le conflit
intime qui menaçait son salut il réussit
à concentrer tous les pouvoirs tout en
maintenant habilement la noblesse sous
son contrôle et en s'éloignant du
dangereux paris mais il resta toujours
tiraillé entre son rôle de puissant roi
soleil chargé de construire et de
soutenir la grandeur de la france et son
devoir vis-à-vis d'un peuple qu'ils
étaient chargés de protéger
l'épisode suivant de notre série mettra
en lumière la façon dont le règne de
louis xiv à donner forme à une culture
riche multiples et puissante
nous visiterons en détail le château de
versailles avec lequel louis xiv ébloui
toute l'europe et fut enviée par le
monde entier
ensuite nous nous intéresserons aux
interminables conflits militaires de
louis xiv
durant son règne une année sur deux se
passa à la guerre et finalement nous
assisterons à la fin de la vie du
monarque sa gloire déclinante
la tragédie qui frappe à sa famille et
l'état de vulnérabilité dans lequel il
laisse à la france
[Musique]